let's get more reaction now to last
night's events joining me from new
jersey is writer for slate magazine
eamon ismail who was at the capitol
building hello to you eamon whereabouts
were you
and and just describe for us what
unfolded around you
i well first of all thank you so much
for having me
i am still in shock i had gotten home
last night very very late so i'm sorry
if i'm going to sound a little drowsy
but
i had gone to the ellipse park at 9 00
a.m yesterday morning
to document the um
you know stop the steel parade march
whatever you want to call it
and i was there when trump asked his
supporters to go to the capitol building
and uh take their country back right so
i followed them
for the 20 blocks that it would take to
get there and
it for the most part was weirdly
calm it felt like i was at comic con
people dressed up as their favorite
characters that they had seen on tv but
obviously as soon as we got to the
capitol building that's when things
started looking very very grim that's
when i started seeing
trump supporters attacking journalists
bullying them
i saw them smashing windows breaking
into the capitol building
shoving police officers you know uh
desecrating desecrating one of the most
important buildings in the country
and quite frankly uh as a reporter you
sort of just need to
stay in the moment and be aware so you
don't get hurt and make sure you're
doing your job correctly but
in the back of my mind i was in shock i
couldn't believe what i was seeing
and what about inside the building
eamonn
the inside the building was a mess there
were hundreds of protesters
going in and out there were there was
some police presence but for the most
part they were docile they didn't
respond to any of the violence they
didn't respond to
anybody breaking anything they tried to
shut the doors
and i've reported on tons and tons and
tons of
protests all over the country and even
outside the country and i've never seen
police
so restrained and if you ask me that's
what the story is here today that the
police
did not intervene they were unprepared
someone has to be held accountable but
you know people were going in going out
taking things rummaging through things
breaking things at their own will
and the police for the most part stood
by and watched and and this protest
didn't come as a surprise it had been
long talked about it was much planned
all week we have been hearing about
protesters planning to descend
on the capital so how were the police so
unprepared as you saw it that's right
uh one would think that they had the
most sophisticated counter-terrorism
measures
in play uh people use um
you know isis tweets and what they say
on
social media networks is intel but here
we have
trump supporters making their plans to
take have a hostile takeover the capitol
building public they were very
very transparent about what they were
planning they were calling it the second
american revolution yet the police were
so ill prepared
they weren't even dressed in riot gear
when the thousands of trump supporters
first ascended on the capitol building
campus it's astonishing it it really
it blows my mind uh i've covered black
lives matter protests
here uh this summer and police were
already in riot gear
in some cases outnumbering the
protesters this was
night and day and i could only have my
own suspicions as to why that was the
case
uh but for the sake of trying to stay
objective i'll keep it to myself
from the way you describe it that there
were there were two very distinct halves
you've written about inside the the
building
those more interested in taking selfies
with various props that they found
inside
versus the very much more aggressive
rioters
that's right the i would say the makeup
of the protesters
were honestly mostly cheerful
like they were happy to be there they
were celebrating people were playing
music on their allowed speakers uh
i'm pretty sure i was hearing the
immigrant song by led zeppelin
which uh is a little ironic but it's a
good song you know
people were there to celebrate people
brought their children there were
children inside that building
it was you know one of the interactions
that i think that will stick with me is
i talked to this
teenager he must have been 17 18 years
old from florida
and he described himself and the
protesters
there as peaceful and i said look in
front of your eyes what do you see
they're breaking the glass they're
kicking in the windows and jumping into
the capitol building
that's violence right he's like yeah i
guess so but it's not as bad as what
antifa does
you know i don't think that they fully
understand
what they were doing and to some degree
you have to
lay blame with the police officers they
were letting them in
they were letting them in i mean uh i
could see that there was some effort to
maintain
and keep people out maintain a perimeter
but they were so overwhelmed that there
was just nothing that they could do
except let them in
so you know uh it's not surprising to me
that some people who were
inside were taking their time going in
looking around
taking pictures leaving coming back
inside taking more pictures
celebrating leaving going back inside it
was
for several hours a lawless place yeah
and and that is the key isn't it the
amount of time
that it took to to regain some kind of
control ayman ismail thank you very much
indeed for getting up so early and
talking to us here on sky news